عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا
واشنطن تربط الحوار مع موسكو بمشاركتك
بوتين يامر بتعزيز القدرات النوويه
الروسيه ومضاعفه تزويد الجيش بالاسلحه
المتطوره
حصيله الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا تتجاوز 50
الف قتيل والصحه العالميه تسعى لضخ المزيد
من المساعده
[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه اعلنت نائبه
السكرتيره الصحفي للبنتاجون ان الولايات
المتحده تبقى على تبقي على قنوات اتصال
مفتوحه مع روسيا وترحب بالحوار مع موسكو
لكنها لن تناقش معها الصراع في اوكرانيا
من دون مشاركه كييف نفسها
واكدت ان الولايات المتحده لم تغير حال
قواتها النوويه بعد قرار روسيا تعليق
مشاركتها في معاهده ستارت مشيره الى ان
الصين ستواجه عقوبات في حال عمقت علاقاتها
مع روسيا
ندد الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بما وصفه بالغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا قائلا
ان ذلك اهانه للضمير الجماعي للمجتمع
الدولي وقال افتتاح الجمعيه العامه
للمنظمه الامميه التي تعقد عشيه الذكرى
السنويه الاولى لبدء الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا حيث قال ان هذه الذكرى تشكل محطه
قاتمه للشعب الاوكراني وان الغزو الروسي
يشكل انتهاكا لمثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي
روسيا الى وقف تهديداتها باحتمال استخدام
السلاح النووي
اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده ستستمر في تزويد قواتها المسلحه
بالمعدات المتقدمه لافتا الى ان موسكو
ستعزز قواتها النوويه وستواصل الانتاج
الضخم لانظمه كنزال لصواريخ الطيران وقال
بوتين ان روسيا ستبدا عمليات التسليم
الجماعيه لصواريخ زيركون الفرد صوتيه التي
تستخدم لتدمير الاهداف البحريه والبريه
مشيرا الى انه سيتم هذا العام نشر صواريخ
سارماتل البالستيلي الباليستيه القادره
على حمل العديد من الرؤوس النوويه
بدوره اتهم السفير الروسي لدى الامم
المتحده
فسيلين الغربه بانه مستعد للتضحيه
باوكرانيا وبالعالم النامي من اجل الحاق
الهزيمه بروسيا بشتى الطرق الممكنه وقال
السفير الروسي في اجتماع خاص للجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها الاوروبيين يتجاهلون ما وصفها
بالنازيه الجديده في اوكرانيا لاستخدام
البلد وسيله لسحق روسيا واتهم هذه الدول
بانها مستعده ليس فقط للتضحيه باوكرانيا
بل لاغراق العالم باسره في الحرب
من جانبه مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل دعا الى
وقف الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا حتى لا
تتعرض اي دوله اخرى في العالم لاعتداء
مماثل وافق قوله
انوي
اذا لم ندين او نوقف افعال روسيا في
اوكرانيا اليوم فان هذا سيزيد من خطر
مواجهه اي دوله اخرى في اي مكان اخر في
العالم لاعتداء مماثل لا يمكن لاحد ان
يشعر بالامان في عالم يتم فيه تطبيع
الاستخدام غير القانوني للقوه
اما السفيره الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده
ليندا توماس امام الجمعيه العامه قالت
اقوى دعت الى بدل مزيد من الجهود لتحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا بما يتوافق مع ميثاق
الامم المتحده ومبادئه الاساسيه وهاب
نقلت صحيفه
جورنال الامريكيه عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان الدول الغربيه تلقت معلومات
استخباريه استخباريه تفيد بان الصين تدرس
ما اذا كان ستزود روسيا بالاسلحه لدعم
حربها في اوكرانيا واضاف المسؤولون انه
يبدو ان موقف بكين من اقتصار دعمها لروسيا
على المساعده الماليه ومشتريات النفط
يتغير الان وفقا لاحدث التقييمات
الاستخباراتيه
اكد رئيس الوزراء السويديه ان محادثات
النيتو مع انقره ستستانف في منتصف الشهر
المقبل موضحا ان المنطقه الاسكندنافيه
تتمتع بشروط فريده وان التعاون سيضيف عمقا
الى النيتو
تصطدم مساعي روسيا لتشكيل تحالف جديد يضم
الهند والصين بعقبات عده ابرزها الخلافات
التي تحكم علاقات البلدين منذ عقود صحيفه
اولستريت جورنال كشفت في تقرير لها ابرزت
تعقيدات في وجه هذا التحالف وموقف كلا
البلدين منه
هذه ليست الجبهه الوحيده التي يريد بوتين
تخطي عقباتها فجبهه لخلق وجمع الحلفاء
ليست موهبه الطريق كما تقول التصريحات
القادمه من الشرق
مدفوعه بتعقد الموقف في حرب اوكرانيا تسعى
موسكو الى تشكيل تحالف يضم الصين والهند
سعي تقيده العلاقات المتازمه بين القوتين
العالميتين بسبب الصراع الحدودي المستمر
بينهما منذ عقود
الصين تريد ان تظل روسيا الى جانبها من
اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب بينما تحاول الهند
امساك العصا من المنتصف
هذه الحقبه ليست وقتا للحرب فالديمقراطيه
والحوار والدبلوماسيه هي سبل المضي قدما
بكين ومنذ ان بدات روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا قدمت دعم اقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا
حاسما لموسكو واشترت منتجات الطاقه
الروسيه واتهمت واشنطن والنيتو بتهيئه
الظروف التي ادت الى الغزو الروسي
وفقا لصحيفه وول ستريجورنال فان مخاوف
القياده الصينيه تتزايد جراء الدعم
العسكري الغربي لاوكرانيا والذي سيضعف
روسيا شريكها السياسي الرئيسي
وتشير سجلات الجمارك الروسيه هذا الشهر
الى ان الصين تقوم في المقابل بشحن معدات
الملاحه وتكنولوجيا التشويش وقطع غيار
المقاتلات الى روسيا ومن
نود ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ان الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين روسيا والصين لم توجه
ابدا ضد طرف ثالث وايضا لا تخضع للتدخل
والاستفزاز من قبل اي طرف ثالث والاكثر من
ذلك لن يطغى عليها الاكراه والضغط من
اطراف ثالثه
تقول الصحيفه ان مقاومه اوكرانيا القويه
في ساحه المعركه دفعت بكين الى اعاده
التفكير وجعلها اكثر ميلا للضغط من اجل
وقف اطلاق النار لمنع المزيد من
الانتكاسات الروسيه او حتى هزيمه على نطاق
واسع تفكير قد يضع حدا للحرب وتداعياتها
افاد المتحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه
ستيفن
ان المستشار الالماني سيستمر في الاتصال
بالكريم لان على الرغم من عدم وجود نتائج
للمحادثات الهاتفيه مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وقال انه من المهم ان تبقى
برلين على اتصالا كون المستشار والحكومه
مقتنعان بذلك مشيرا في الوقت ذاته ان
الحكومه لا ترى رغبه بوتين في وقف الحرب
[تصفيق]
تراشق وانتقادات متبادله بين الدفاع
الروسيه وتصريحات قائد مجموعه فاجنر التي
تحمل رسائل خفيه تعكس خفيه تعكس حجم
التوتر الحاصل والتي تنذر بحدوث ازمه
عسكريه اضافيه للوضع الميداني المعقد الذي
يواجهه او تواجهه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الاوساط الروسيه منشغله هذه الايام
بالخلاف المعلني بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
تيفاجنر اخر التصريحات مطالبه قائد فاغنر
بالضغط الشعبي على مؤسسه الجيش لتزويد
مقاتله في باخموت بالذخيره الدعوه تحمل
اتهامات مبطنه لوزير الدفاع بتعمد تعطيل
وصول الذخيره والسلاح الى جبهات القتال
مراقبون يرون ان جدوى الانقسام يغذيها
تعطل حسم المعارك في باخموت وبعضهم يرى
انها محاوله من قائد فاجنر لتبرير عدم حسم
معركه بخموت بالقاء اللوم على الجيش في
موقف ممثل لقائد الشيشان الذي حمل قاده في
الجيش الروسي الاخفاق فيليمان وزير الدفاع
الروسي ما يزال يلتزم الصمت تجاه اتهامات
فاغنر لكن الجيش تعرض لتغيرات كثيره لقاده
المعارك خلال العام الاول من الحرب في
اوكرانيا الصراع بين الجيش الروسي وفاجنر
يشير الى حاله من الانقسام ستكون لها
ارتدادات مع استمرار المعارك وهو الامر
الذي دفع بالرئيس الروسي الى توعد من
وصفهم بالخونه داخل روسيا بالعقاب
قال الرئيس الامريكي انه لم يقرا قرار
فلاديمير بوتين بتعليق المشاركه في معاهده
الاسلحه النوويه مؤقتا كاشاره الى ان
الرئيس الروسي يفكر في استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه ووصف بايدن قرار بوتين بالخطا
الفادح واعتبره غير مسؤول
الرئيس
روسيا علقت معاهده نيو ستارت فما العواقب
المحتمله لهذا القرار
معاهده نيو ستارت اخر معاهده عسكريه
متبقيه بين الروس والامريكيين
بعد اعلان بوتين تعليق بلاده المشاركه
فيها يخشى الكثير من سباق التسلح النووي
محتمل
المعاهده ستنتهي في غضون الف يوم تقريبا
لكن نهايتها قد تكون بدايه لعهد عسكري
جديد
لكن يخشى الخبراء ان تكون نهايتها بدايه
عهد جديد من الرضع النووي تتشجع فيه كوريا
الشماليه والصين لتوسيع ترسمتهما النوويه
يقول جون ورفال كبير مستشار جلوبال زيرو
مع خرق روسيا لنيوستارت وتطوير الصين
اسلحتها النوويه واختبارات الصاروخيه
واستمرار تخصيب ايران لليورانيوم فاننا
امام فتره سيئه للاستقرار النووي بالعالم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
زلزالنا بقوه 6.8 درجات يضرب طاجكستان قرب
الحدود مع الصين
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اعلنا وزير الداخليه التركيه
سليمان
المدمر ارتفع الى 43
الفته وخمسين وكانت اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه اعلنت ان البلاد تعرضت
لسبعه الاف ومئتين واربعين هزه ارتداديه
منذ زلزال السادس من فبراير
المرصد السوري اعلن قبل ذلك ارتفاع
حصيلتها اعداد ضحايا الزلزال في الشمال
السوري الى قرابه
6750 شخصا واكد المرصد ان المئات لا
يزالون في حال حرجه المرصده اشار ايضا الى
ان عدد الضحايا السوريين الذين تم ادخالهم
من المعابر التركيه الى سوريا منذ السادس
من فبراير بلغ 1793
حزن مؤجل ممرضون واطباء سوريون نحو نحو
بعاطفتهم نحو بعاطفاتهم جانبا للاهتمام
بالجرحى الذين تدفقوا للمشافي عاقبه زلزال
في مقابله خاصه للعربيه تحدثت مبرده في
احدى مشافي حارم في ادلب عن هول ما راته
وعن تحولها اما لبعض الاطفال في المشفى
باصابه طفيفه وجروح قابله للتضميض وان
حفرت بعقولهم نالوا الفرصه الثانيه اطفال
اخرجوا من تحت الانقاض ليفترشوا اسره احد
مشافي حار في ريف ادلب هؤلاء يرون بمن
يعاملهم من ممرضات حضن ام فقدوها او اخفي
عنهم مصيرها
فريضه اسمها جنان جنان جنيد هي من اطفال
اللي طلعت من تحت الانقاض هاي جنان عندي
اياها يعني
ما عندي اولاد فحس فبحسه مثل بنتي خط
الدفاع الاول في الكارثه هذه المره
تشاركته مجموعتانه ففي وقت كان عناصر
الخوض البيضاء منتشرين بين الانقاض
يتتبعون اطراف خيطان علهم يجدون صوتا هنا
او يدا هناك تلتمس من ياخذ بها كان
الاطباء وطاقم التمريض على قله عناصره
يهرعون من زاويه الى اخرى لمحاوله انقاذ
من ياتهم بعضهم لفظ انفاسه الاخيره على
مداخل المشافي واخرون على ايديهم
يجيبوا لي الطفل فانا عم باخده فبيقولوا
لي عايش عايش فبجي
بيكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون راحت الضحايا الزلزال
كانت ممرضه معنا جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى
فنحن عرفناه استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه
والتفتنا لغيره
مات الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسا عايشه
لسه بدها ايانا فنحن رحنا لهنيك هل حزن
المؤجل رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت
مالوفه في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12
عاما لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف
في كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد
ويقول لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات
لربما من ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خزنتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجى انقاذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقف وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان
قلت منظمه الصحه العالميه انها ستستفيد او
ستستفيد من التخفيف المؤقت للعقوبات
المفروضه على سوريا المصممه للسماح بتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه بسهوله اكبر في البلد
الذي مزقته الحرب المدمره بعد هذا الزلزال
منظمه الصحه العالميه تتحرك بسرعه كبيره
الان مع شركائنا للاستفاده من هذا التوقف
المؤقت في العقوبات لقد بدانا بالفعل في
طلب المعدات والامدادات ونحن نعمل مع
شركاء الامم المتحده على نهج جماعي
للاستفاده من التوقف
ضرب زلزال بقوه 6.8 درجات شرقاطجكستان
صباح اليوم وفق ما اعلنت هيئه المسح
الجيولوجيه الامريكيه وقالت الهيئه ان
مركز الزلزال يقع على عمق 20.5 كيلو متر
وحددت الهيئه مركز الزلزال في كورنو بعدا
خشان وهي منطقه تتمتع بحكم شبه ذاتيه وتقع
في شرق تاجس تايكستان على الحدود مع كل من
افغانستان والصين
قال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبيل ان ايران تشكل مصدر قلق
رئيسي للعديد من الدول في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط منذ تجميد محادثات احياء الاتفاق
النووي مشيرا الى ان ذلك يتزامن مع تكثيف
العلاقات بين طهران وروسيا واضافها في
بيان انه يشعر بالقلق ايضا اذا تدهور
الاوضاع في الشرق الاوسط حيث يؤدي توسيع
المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه الى تفاقم
حده التوتر فضلا عن تاخير التوصل الى حل
سلمي للصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
اطلق اطلقت صواريخ عده فجر اليوم الخميس
من غزه باتجاه اسرائيل وفق ما افاد شهود
وعيان في القطاع الفلسطيني والجيش
الاسرائيلي وقال شهود انما لا يقل عن
ثمانيه صواريخ اطلقت من القطاع باتجاه
اسرائيل بينما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيان انه رصد اطلاق سته صواريخ من القطاع
خمسه منها اعترضها منظومه القبه الحديديه
في حين سقط الصاروخ السادس في منطقه غير
ماهوله
لنا مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم المتحده رياض
منصور في لقاء مع العربيه الاعمال
الاسرائيليه في نابلس وانا اشهد منصور
مجلس الامن والمجتمع الدولي تحمل
مسؤولياتهم وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للشعب
الفلسطيني نحن ندين هذه الاعمال
الاسرائيليه باشد العبارات ونريد لمجلس
الامن ونريد للمجتمع الدولي وللاميد العام
شخصيا ان يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم في تطبيق ما
اقر سواء في مجلس الامن ام عبر تقرير
الامين العام في توفير الحمايه للسكان
المدنيين وسنتواصل مع اعضاء مجلس الامن في
الايام القادمه لان يتحمل المجلس
مسؤولياته وان تعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
طارئه وفق ما اشرت اليه في تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الدكتور رياض المالكي وهذه
التعليمات التي لدي من قبل القياده
الفلسطينيه واشكر الاشق العرب على وقوفهم
معنا في هذا المجال
الخارجيه السعوديه اعربت عن ادانه استنكار
المملكه الشديدين لاقتحام قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه نابلس الفلسطينيه ما ادى
الى سقوط ضحايا واصابه اخرين واكدت
الوزاره رفض المملكه التام لما تقوم به
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من انتهاكات
خطيره للقانون الدولي مشدده على مطالبتها
للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاع بمسؤوليته لانهاء
الاحتلال ووقف التصعيد والاعتداء
الاسرائيلي وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين
تعتزم مع الولايات المتحده اعاده 77 قطعه
اثريه منهوبه من اليمن بعد عرضها في متحف
بواشنطن لمده عامين على الاقل بموجب اتفاق
مع الحكومه اليمنيه موضحه ان الخطوه تاتي
بعد تعاون عدد من الوكالات الامريكيه
والحكوميه والحكومه اليمنيه
لاستعاده عدد من الاثار المهربه والمعروضه
للبيع في السوق السوداء في حين عبرت
السلطات اليمنيه عن امتنانها العميق
للخطوه الامريكيه
قصه نجاح يسجلها اليمن هذه المره من
واشنطن مع استعاده حوالي 80 قطعه اثريه
منهوبه ومهربه الى الولايات المتحده
الاعلان عن هذا الانجاز اتى في حفل اقيم
على شرف الجهات التي عملت على رصد هذه
القطع ومصادرتها السفير اليمني في
الولايات المتحده محمد الحضرمي اعرب عالم
امتنانه الشديد للجهود الامريكيه التي
افضت الى استعاده هذه القطع الشاهده على
تاريخ وتراث اليمن العريق كلنا ان شاء
الله سنعمل في المستقبل القريب خلال
اسابيع على التوقيع على
مذكره تفاهم مع الخارجيه الامريكيه لضمان
استمرار هذا العمل وهو عدم سرقه الاثار
اليمنيه وان تم سرقتها ترصدها واعادتها
الى الشعب اليمني
الولايات المتحده سلمت السلطات اليمنيه
اربعه وستين راسا حجريا منحوتا و 11 صفحه
مخطوطه من المصحف ووعاء منقوشا من البرونز
وشاهد جنائزيه من ثقافات معين في مرتفعات
شمال غرب اليمن ويرجع تاريخها الى القرن
الاول قبل الميلاد
هذه قطع يمنيه من التراث اليمني هو حقيقه
ان العديد من الوكالات والمنظمات المختلفه
كان عليها التعاون معا لتحقيق ذلك وجميعهم
ممثلون هنا اليوم ويمكن ان نرى المحيط
الذي يشعر به الناس فاغلبيتهم لم يسودوا
اليمن ولكنهم يطوقون الى التعرف على
الحضاره اليمنيه
الحكومه اليمنيه ستسمح لمتحف سميثونيوم في
واشنطن بالاحتفاظ بهذه القطع لمده عامين
بموجب اتفاق وقع بين الطرفين يسمح
بالمحافظه على هذه القطع من جهه وبالترويج
لليمن الغني بثقافته والحضارات التي
تعاقبت على ارضه
طريق طويل سلكتها هذه الاثار حتى استعادها
اليمن من جديد عينه صغيره من مئات القطع
الاثريه التي تحاول الحكومه استعادتها بعد
نهبها وتهريبها خارج البلاد فلت سليمان
العربيه واشنطن
في نهايه النشره هذا التذكير بابرز
العناوين
عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب في اوكرانيا
واشنطن تربط الحوار مع موسكو بمشاركه
يامر بتعزيز القدرات النوويه الروسيه
ومضاعفه تزويد الجيش بالاسلحه المطوره
حصيله الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا تتجاوز 50
الف قتيلو الصحه العالميه تسعى لضخ المزيد
من المساعده
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]